hi I'm Jonathan Gerard of Cambridge
University and we'll from research and
I'll be talking about automated theorem
proving and axiomatic mathematics so
kind of giving an introduction to the
current status of our functionality for
automating pure mathematics in version
12 and this is a quick look at things to
come and in version 4.1 and beyond
the plan is to give a very brief
overview of our current automated
theorem proving functionality and the
functionality for doing axiomatic
representation of pure mathematics in
version 12 and and to give a brief
glimpse of things to come in version 12
one and and beyond okay so let me start
by saying so with most computer algebra
systems including for a long time the
Wolfram language there's very much an
emphasis on doing kind of forward
computation where you give some explicit
calculation you say you know evaluate
this integral solve this differential
equation factorize this quadratic
whatever and you get back the result and
for many branches of applied mathematics
and theoretical physics and so on that's
extremely useful because people are
interested in doing explicit
calculations but in pure mathematics
this is sort of the the the use case of
that has been much less clear because
pure mathematicians in general are
interested not so much in doing
calculations been improving theorems
which is sort of the inverse problem of
this and like most inverse problems it
turns out to be many orders of magnitude
more difficult than the forward problem
so there are several reasons for that
and one of which is is kind of
algorithmic we know that there are a
bunch of these limited results from
mathematical logic and threat achill
computer science like girls first
incompleteness theorem tuskys theorem on
the undefined ability of the truth
predicate Turing's theorems on
undecidability of the the halting
problem in the end China's problem and
so on there's there's also a more kind
of philosophical or conceptual
difficulty which is that it's not
entirely clear what a proof should be I
mean there are kind of two mutually
contradictory downards sort of
objectives of proving something one is
one is kind of a piston logical to sort
of convince you that a theorem is true
and the other is more pedagogical to
kind of explain why it's true and to a
certain extent those are opposed because
you know the the the more convincing a
proof is the more formal it is the more
computable it is in general the less
comprehensible it is so we want to have
something that kind of makes the balance
between automated proof verification and
being as close to something that the
water language can just automatically
verify as possible whilst also
maintaining some degree of
comprehensibility and there's also a
more data curation
oriented problem which is in order for
this to be useful for actual pure
mathematics you need to have not just
very good they're improving algorithms
but you also need to know a lot about
math you need to have you know a very
large collection of a large curated
corpus of mathematical information and
so there's a whole side to the company
which I'm not going to talk so much
about today which is the semantic
representations project where in effect
we're trying to take the roughly 5
million or so theorems it that exist in
the published literature of math
Maddox and the many more millions of
kind of objects and definitions and
axioms they're based upon and get them
to the point where they can be their
formal and computable and kind of can be
fed directly into a theorem proving
pipeline and I'll mention that a little
bit today but it's not so much the
emphasis of this talk but okay let me
start at the beginning so for a long
time the Wolfram language has had kind
of subterranean theorem proving
functionality behind functions like full
simplify and reduce but much more
recently in version 11 3 we released the
first sort of serious they're improving
function which is this thing called find
equational proof which is so it approves
arbitrary theorems in what's called
first-order equation or logic which is a
restriction of first-order logic in
which one has only universal quantifiers
and in which equality is the only
built-in predicate and that's a
significant restriction but it still
turns out to be sufficient to encode
effectively any algebraic theory so if
you want to do group theory ring theory
loop theory certain parts of field
theory universal algebra boolean logic
anything like that you know fine
equational proof can do that so in its
simplest case it takes essentially the
same syntax as full simplify you give it
a statement you want to prove like a
equals C and a list of assumptions from
which to prove it I equals B B equals C
so let's prove really trivial theorem
that kind of is representing
transitivity of the Equality predicate
here so we get the back this this very
simple proof object that's telling us
actually that's kind of small I'm not
sure we can make that any bigger
possibly I'm already quite zoomed in
that's telling us that we have five
steps in that proof object and if we can
get back this the sort of graphical
representation of the proof so you see
we start with these two axioms up here
we're trying to prove this hypothesis a
equals C is actually true in the process
of doing that we proved some
intermediate substitution lemma that's
not a very interesting example okay
here's a slightly more interesting
example here we're gonna define some
axioms of group theory here are sort of
symbolic representations of
associativity right identity in right
inverse and we're going to prove that
from that the the property of left
identity also holds which is a somewhat
non-trivial
derivation okay so we get that we get
the result back this time it's telling
us that there were eleven steps in that
proof it's a slightly more complicated
proof object I can request back a data
set version of this proof oops sorry
shouldn't press right and I'm going to
say that the multiplication operator
which we chose to be gee I'm going to
typeset that using a center dot and we
get back this thing called approve data
set which has the so we have the axioms
of group theory at the top we have the
hypothesis that we're trying to prove
and then for each of these intermediate
lemmas we can go we can drill down and
we can see exactly how that intermediate
line
was proved we can see it you know we
applied a particular rule that have to a
particular part specification of a
different result and I'm gonna explain a
little bit more about what exactly this
proof object means and what's happening
internally in just a moment but as well
as well as getting back a dataset
representation we could also get back a
sort of more human readable thing so we
can request this thing called a proof
notebook where it will actually go and
synthesize a natural language version of
this proof that's the formatter there's
a notebook object that we can then break
away and do stuff with so you should you
know note that the input for the rule
contains a sub pattern of the form blah
blah blah but as well as reading the
proof you can also actually run it so
one thing you can do is request back the
proof function which will take okay so
here we have the axioms and the
hypotheses formulated the symbolic
pieces of Wolfram language code and then
each substitution lemma in effect each
each application of a replacement
operation in this proof is then
explicitly specified using a kind of map
out and replace operation apply to an
intermediate result and so then with the
result of that is you can just take this
thing and we can run it and we can
verify that the theorem is actually true
and so Kay has slightly more interesting
theorem and group theory that I'm not
going to explain I'm sorry clear on that
wait why is that not evaluating that's
concerning stop working
it's stuck running something
what is it stuck running sorry about
this
oh sorry I accidentally ran the largest
computation in this notebook but that's
okay there we go it didn't actually
synthesize something I think so we can
get back this yeah sorry I accidentally
ran the next exact so I was gonna show a
simple theorem and group theory I
accidently iyx and he ran the next
example which was an open research
problem for a long time which was
proving that that this is okay so this
this here is a specification of an axiom
for boolean logic that was presented by
Stephen in in nks it defines the NAND
operator or the chef a stroke operator
and here we're going to prove that from
that all of the standard algebraic
properties of the NAND operation of the
operators still apply and so this was an
extremely complicated automated
derivation you'll see it took 309 steps
which is why my notebook froze for a
moment and this is the derivation but
that didn't take more than a few seconds
to evaluate once I realized what was
going on okay so fine equational proof
will return a proof object if and only
if full simplify would have returned
would have evaluated to true for that
given equation of logic theorem and as I
say I'll explain a bit more about the
internal structure of the proof object
in just a moment and internally what
it's doing is it's implementing a bunch
of these algorithmic techniques for
doing superposition and calculus and
equation logic
thanks to do with power modulation and
truth index completion unfailing
completion and so on a bunch of
algorithms that come from universal
algebra which I'll try and give a very
brief explanation of in just a moment
but okay let me talk about something new
that came in version 12 so in addition
to a bunch of updates to find equational
proof we also released this function
called axiomatic theory which kind of
gives you a way of interfacing with fine
equational proof that's a little bit
more user-friendly
so the idea is you specify a
specification of a standard axiom system
from mathematics and you get back a list
containing computable forms of those
axioms that can be fed directly into a
theorem proving framework so axiomatic
theory we can we can request the axioms
for boolean algebra and we get these
back sort of typeset using using
standard like circle times operators and
things like that we could get back for
instance the axiom for group theory we
store a bunch of metadata for each of
these axiomatic theories so we can
request for instance the list of super
theory so these are the list of theories
axiomatic theory knows about that
implement group theory is a kind of
subset of its axioms so one of those for
instance is a billion group theory
because that's just the same but with
the axiom of commutativity you'll see
that we hit we have this this default
choice of operators you know multiple
goes to circle times and the identity
goes to one tilde and so on if we want
to do we can get back a we can we can
see what that default operator choice is
and we can choose to modify it so we can
if we pass axiomatic theory a list
containing the name of the axiom system
and then an association we can choose to
override the default operator choice so
let's say multiplication goes to G
inverse goes to in identity goes to e
and we get back a sort of a new version
of the group theory operator group
theory axioms using our own choice of
operators and we can ok another piece of
metadata we could have requested was a
list of notable theorems so you know
that the the inverse of the I of the
inverse gets you back to the original
element and then if we want to do if we
if we if we get our overridden our
version of group theory where that with
our own operator override and we request
back the notable theorems of course the
notable theorems then get rewritten
using the new operator choice and so
when you do things like modify the
choice of operators an axiomatic theory
the function is khloe is sort of smart
enough to know that it should propagate
those changes down into all of the
metadata and if you then try and prove
things about super theories and so on it
will it will adjust to do that as well
so let's give a quick example of that
let's use actually Matic theory with
with our new choice of group theory
operators let's and let's pick the
notable theorem inverse of composite
that a compose be all inverse is equal
to B inverse compose a inverse so let's
prove that and we get back a proof
object with 19 steps and so this is the
this is the derivation and so it's kind
of the plan is you know right now
axiomatic theory just has support for
equational axiom systems because we
currently only have equation what
they're improving but in future versions
of the language as I'll explain in a
moment we're going to have much more
sophisticated they're improving
algorithms so the the range of theories
that axiomatic theory has access to will
grow over time and kind of eventually
the plan is to have any kind of
reasonable field of pure mathematics
represented purely computable in the
form of an axiomatic theory or a sort of
entity so internally because a chromatic
theory is having to do all these
non-trivial computations to do with
operator overrides and things it's not
actually format as an entity store but
you can basically treat it like it's an
entity store because it has exactly the
same internal kind of syntax okay so one
point of one point that's that's
definitely worth clarifying with find
equational proof is what it can't do so
one thing that definitely can't do is
deal with sort of arithmetic operators
out of box now there are very good
reasons for doing this so if this is a
point of confusion when many people
first use this function is they try and
prove
something like you know 4 X minus minus
X equals ax right that's obviously a
theorem that's true in arithmetic but
fine equational proofs will complain at
you if you try and prove it there are
many reasons for this one is a very
simple reason which is that on the
Wolfram language front end if you give
it a statement like minus minus x equals
x it will just auto evaluate to true and
so find equational proof is then trying
to find a proof of the statement true
given a set of axioms but there's
actually a deeper reason why we don't
support this we could override it you
could put it in hold holes and so on but
the deeper reason why we don't make this
work is because the whole point we find
equational proof is that you specify the
axiom system you specify the set of
assumptions if you use an arithmetic
operator there isn't a canonical accent
Asian Accent ization of arithmetic do
you mean some equation if you use a Plus
do you want to use some equational for
more arithmetic do you want to use piano
arithmetic and if so which version do
use the first other version the second
older version do you want to use
presberg arithmetic something we have
decidability it's it's not at all clear
if you use operators that have well that
have predefined meanings it's not clear
what kind of what base what's the
correct basis to kind of to start from
in doing that and so maybe once we have
access to many more axiomatic systems we
can have some kind of super function
that will figure out what a reasonable
axiomatization is but at least for the
time being we think it's safer to kind
of let the user to find exactly what
they want to assume so if you want to
you can easily prove this theorem but
you have to define your own operate your
own axioms of arithmetic or use ones
that will be built into axiomatic theory
so here for instance I'm defining axioms
that that sort of specify the plus and
minus operations and so on so here we
get back the proof object of that we get
back this data set which because we've
used our own operator choice gets
formatted in a slightly ugly way with
these kind of plus and minus operators
but of course we can we can always
override those and we can use our own
choice of type setting so we can tighten
set that a little bit more elegantly
there okay
so let me now explain what these proof
objects really mean and and to do that I
kind of have to explain a little bit
about what fine equational proof is
doing internally but we start with a
slightly conceptual question of what
actually is a proof well through a
fundamental kind of meta mathematical
point of view an axiom particularly an
axiom of the form x equals y for
instance can really be thought of as
being a pair of symbolic transformation
rules what it's really saying is that if
you have an R if you have an expression
that looks like X you can replace it
with one that looks like Y and vice
versa and so then a theorem particularly
an equation of theorem where you're
saying you know prove a
cause be is really just the the
statement that there exists some
sequence of axiomatic transformations
starting from a that the terminates of B
and then the problem and then the proof
is that particular sequence and so the
problem if they're improving is to find
that sequence of rewrite operations so
you know here is a here are some
examples that actually come from n KS of
you know his proof of commutativity of
the NAND operator given axioms at the
top here defining transmitted symbolic
transformation rules and here you can
see where each of these transformation
rules is getting applied here's a kind
of ultimately dessicated form of the
same idea so given this very very
abstract symbolic representation of
three axioms at the bottom here are sort
of proofs of seven abstract theorems
where you know each each symbolic
expression is just a sequence of black
and white boxes okay but that seems
fairly straightforward so why is there
improving difficult well at a
fundamental level the reason why theorem
proving is hard is because most
mathematical axiom systems do not give
rise to what are called confluence term
rewriting systems so some term so some
abstract rewrite systems have this very
nice property called confluence or the
church-rosser property which loosely
speaking says that the ordering of the
order of application of rewrite rules
doesn't matter you can just apply the
rules in any order and the result that
you get back is in some sense invariant
to that choice so they're improving over
confluent rewrite systems particularly
ones that are strongly normalizing so
there any rewrite operation eventually
terminates that a normal form there
improving in those systems is really
really easy because if you want to prove
that x equals y then what you can do if
it's strongly normalizing and confluent
is you can just you can apply any random
rewrite sequence to X any random rewrite
sequence to Y and then because this
because the system is strongly
normalizing they're guaranteed to
terminate on some normal form and
because the system is confluent it's
guaranteed that if they terminate on the
same normal form then the expressions
were equivalent and if they don't they
weren't so the problem that the
difficult part of their improving is how
can we take an arbitrary rewrite system
generated by some mathematical axiom
system and produce an equivalent one or
for some loose definition of equivalence
that has this nice property of
confluence so to do that this is what we
this is the so-called Knuth Bendix
completion algorithm or the unfailing
completion algorithm that we use that
came from loop theory and universal
algebra and the idea is to exploit this
property this result in mathematical
logic that says a term rewriting system
is strut is confluent if and only if
every critical pair converges so a
critical pair is a way of sort of making
precise this idea that the that the
order
application of rules matters so one so
if you have a non compliment system then
you could start from a single liquid
from an expression a and you could apply
and from that expression you could
derive two distinct expressions B and C
for instance by applying two different
rules in in different so by by either
applying to different replacement rules
or by part by applying the same
replacement rule in with two different
part specifications so a critical pair
is basically representing an ambiguity
in the term in the evolution of the term
in writing system and so we say that
that critical pair converges if given
this pair BC if there exists a rewrite
sequence that goes that takes B to D and
the rewrite sequence is a sequence that
takes C to D then we say that critical
pair converges to D and there's this
there's this theorem that says that if
you have a strongly normalizing system
then it's confluent if and only if every
one of these critical pairs converges so
all we have to do to make that to do
theorem proving really is to compute
critical pairs and force them to
converge and that's exactly what find
equational proof does it and the way
that we do that is very very simple we
just say well if B if this pair B and C
could be derived from a single common
expression by applying the rewrite rules
then B and C must be equivalent so we
can treat that like a lemma we just add
a lemma to the system that says B equals
C and when we do that because of what I
explained earlier we then get a pair of
rewrite rules that says B can go to C so
you can go to B and we immediately force
that pair to converge and the idea is if
we keep doing that over and over we keep
computer critical pairs keep adding them
dilemmas to the system eventually we'll
end up with something that confluent now
of course eventually girdle wins and we
get bitten by undecidability and it's
not guaranteed that this process will
terminate and you might go on computing
critical pairs indefinitely but actually
in most practical cases this turns out
to be sufficient for doing serious
they're improving so that's that's the
essential idea of how finally there's a
bunch of other stuff that I don't really
have time to explain but I have you to
address any questions but that's the
that's essentially how fine equational
proof works okay so let me now talk a
little bit about things to could that
are not in version 12 but will be coming
in version 12.1 and beyond actually this
is a weird order let me do it let me do
it this way round so this is something
that will be coming in 12 1
we think so this is support for full
first-order logic not restricted to just
the equational case so actually it turns
out you can do this just using the kind
of algorithmic framework that we already
have basically because there exists a
range of these these techniques and the
main one of which is this thing called
skolemization
which lets us essentially take an
arbitrary statement in first order logic
skolemization then shifts all the
quantifiers to one side and gets rid
does the quantifier elimination to get
rid of all the existential quantifiers
so you just have firstly you just have
universal quantifiers and then you have
a first-order logic
sort of statement on the right and then
the idea is you can just set that equal
to a tautology in boolean logic and then
that that gives you an equation in
boolean algebra that that's true if and
only if the original first-order
expression is true now it's not quite
logical equivalence it's something it's
a slightly weaker condition called echo
satisfiability but it turns out to be
sufficient for doing theorem proving so
in in the next version of fine
equational proof the idea is for us to
have support for first-order for full
first-order logic there improving using
this framework so here's a very simple
sort of syllogism in first order logic
proving that Socrates is mortal you know
this is this is the proof draw for that
this is the data set that's probably
going to typeset horribly because I just
modified the code it's not too bad okay
this is a slightly more complicated
thing because it's having to do the
quantifier elimination because we have
an existential quantifier here we're
saying prove that there exists some X
such the XS mortal and we get a slightly
more complicated proof graph okay here's
here's a logic puzzle that comes from
the comes from Lewis Carroll actually I
think so you know every baby is a
logical everyone who can manage a
crocodile has not despised everyone who
is the logical is despised and proved
that there does not exist an X such that
X is a baby and X ax can manage a
crocodile right that's a logic puzzle
might take you a couple minutes to do if
you're a human but fine equational proof
can do it almost immediately
although the proof ends up being
somewhat somewhat non-trivial here's an
even more complicated logic puzzle this
is the so-called knights and knaves
puzzle I won't bother to walk you
through it but turns out Zoe's a knight
and Mel is a knave and fine equational
proof could work that out and again we
get this we get this rather complicated
proof graph but because because equation
logic they're improving is so efficient
this doesn't take very long to
synthesize at all and in fact this this
turns out to be in many in many cases
much much faster than doing the
equivalent resolution theorem proving
over the over the full first order logic
term which is why we've chosen this
particular approach there are kind of
longer term projects to support higher
order logics and resolution theorem
proving in first-order logic as well as
things like modal logic and temporal
logic and so on but at least for the
time being this is this is kind of what
we've been working on oh ok so um one
other thing that I just wanted to
mention that I think what probably won't
be in version 12.1 but will be some
variant of this will be available in a
future
possibly in 12 - is a is a more modeled
theoretic thing so so everything I've
mentioned so far has been purely
syntactical just reasoning over the
terms as syntactical objects but there's
also this whole question of semantics
and actually giving interpretations to
these terms so one one situation is can
you can you find models such that
particular theories hold or particular
theories are falsified and one situation
where that's really useful is if you
have if you ask if they're improving
algorithm to prove something that's
actually false
so with fine equational proof if we say
you know find a proof of this theorem
which is which can't be so we can't
prove that a a equals c on the basis of
the a equals b and in this is very very
simple case where there's actually only
a finite proof tree fine equational
proof can just navigate that proof tree
and say okay i didn't find a proof it
failed but in the case where there are
universal quantifiers and the proof tree
is infinite we can't do that so here's a
false proof in group theory or here I'm
asking to prove a false theorem in group
theory but if I just try and run this
it's gonna run forever until I bought it
or put a time constraint or something so
one thing will be really nice is to have
a way of saying actually I found a
counter example for this and so we have
this function that provisionally called
find equational counter example although
the name will probably change where if I
feed in the same specification it knows
that that result is false because it
found a counter example then the counter
example is this model theoretic thing so
if I get back this Association what it
does is it gives an actual semantic
interpretation to the terms it says
here's an actual pure function that
denotes this G operator so it's saying
slot 1 plus slot 2 modulo 2 and it's
saying the inverse operation should be
modulo slot 1 modulo 2 and then we give
an actual interpretations of the terms
so that the identity operator is zero
and the counter example corresponds to
the case where x equals 1 and if we want
to confirm that that is in fact a
counter example we can request back the
falsification function which is likely
the dual of the proof function so if we
now call the sets up of the hole
falsification thing and if we now run
this we get that we get the validation
that this is indeed a valid counter
example to that result okay so that's a
very there's si there's a lot more still
to come you know we've really only
scratched the surface with what we want
to do with with logic and they're
improving here but I hope I've given you
at least some indication of what we're
currently doing and what what's plan for
the future and I'm happy to take any
questions Thanks
you